[Music]
this season on keeping up with the
kardashians
is full of drama and lots of intense
conversations
when you're on this journey it is you
have to be really vulnerable and it's
emotional and really really hard
and it isn't getting easier for khloe
kardashian
in a trailer for the show's 19th season
premiering thursday
chloe and tristan thompson have a
serious one-on-one about their
relationship
one of my fears is you're acting like
this until you get what you want and
then if you do
you're gonna turn into like the old
tristan again yep
you know the old tristan he did kiss me
my family was ruined tristan
might love me whatever that means he has
no respect for me whatsoever
the cheating scandal might be a thing in
the past but it doesn't mean
these two exes don't have a lot to hash
out
i think this is a part of life i'm not
saying it was unfortunate
yeah another fear coco has moving in
with tristan
i need casa su casa who knows can just
live there forever
[Music]
it's not happening yup in another promo
for keeping up
tristan wants chloe and their
two-year-old daughter true to live in
his la home
forever i have my house in la i'd love
for you and true to stay there
for as long as you guys need to and i'll
give you guys a key nice try tristan
nice try stop it
it's not happening oh my god but you can
always count on baby true to bring
these two parents together we're gonna
swing you here hold this hand we're
gonna swing you
and regardless of chloe's doubts e.t
confirmed in august that the pair was
officially back together
and things have been going well with a
couple i'm just
super happy and content and i'm focused
on work and like taking care of me my
body and soul and
true the source told et that chloe's
doing what she feels is right for
herself
and her daughter true chloe has never
listened to outside voices
she's always stayed true to her heart
things with chloe and tristan have been
great and the couple is taking this time
in quarantine to really reconnect and
enjoy one another
you can go through hell and high water
but you can still come out
and have a beautiful positive happy life